استدعاء وزير الخارجيه البريطانيين جيمس
كليفر القائم بالاعمال الايراني للاحتجاج
على احكام جديده بالاعدام في حق متظاهرين
كما اعلنت الخارجيه الفرنسيه انها ستستدعي
القائمه بالاعمال الايراني في باريس اليوم
لابلاغه بادانتها الشديده لعمليه الاعداء
وما وصفاته بالقمع الحالي في البلاد
كما استدعت الخارجيه الالمانيه السفير
الايرانيه في برلين مره اخرى للاحتجاج على
اعدام ايرانيين اثنين على صله بالمظاهره
سيبوني صغير
الحكومه الالمانيه تدين بشده استمرار
ايران في استخدام عقوبه الاعدام وسيله
للقمل تدعو الحكومه الالمانيه النظام
الايرانيه مره اخرى وبشكل عاجل الى عدم
تنفيذ المزيد من احكام الاعدام والغاء
عقوبه الاعدام على الفور ذنبا الى جنب مع
صوره كائن الدوليين سنواصلوا زياده الضغط
على النظام الايراني والعمل من اجل
احترامي حقوق الانسان
البانيه عيسى فيما يتعلق بهذه المظاهرات
وعلى ماذا تتحفظ وتحتاج بالضبط
نعم ايمان هذه المره الرابعه لاستدعاء
السفير الايراني ثلاث مرات تتذكرها السنه
الماضيه لكن هذه المره جائت بمتزامنه ايضا
من دعوه من المستشار الالماني وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه قالت بان هذا
الاستدعاء هو اشاره بان القمع الوحشي هكذا
وصفاته لن يمردون عقاب بانه امر لن نقبل
به على الاطلاق ايضا تحدثت المستشاره عن
الحزمه الرابعه للعقوبات المتخصصه في شان
حقوق الانسان على طهران تحدثت عن ان هذه
الحزمه الرابعه ستموس القياده الكبرى في
الحرس الثوري الايراني المستشاره الالماني
بدوره ايضا ذكر عدد اسماء همم شخصين من
ضمن الذين تم اعدامهم وهو محمد الحسين
ومحمد كرامه قال بان هذا الامر
مضجع وانه يدعو ال- ال- النظام الايراني
الى وقف الاعدامات وعدم استخدام لترهيب
الشعب ايضا المتحدث باسم الحكومه
الالمانيه وصفها بما قاله النظام الايراني
ان يكف عن هذه الاعمال الوحشيه هذا هو
ملخص الموقف الايراني الذي استدعاه طبعا
الاستدعاء كان للمره الرابعه لكن ايضا
لابد ان اتذكر بان المانيا في هذا
الاستدعاء ايضا وضعت قاعده وهو الموقف
الرسمي الالماني بان الله محدثات مع يرى
في الملف انه الايراني ما دم هناك قمه
للاحتجاج وهو موقف ينفصل تماما عن المواقف
الاخرى الاوروبيه التي حيث وضعت المانيا
شرطا مباشره محدثات النوويه مع ايران مع
وقف همم الهجمات على المحتاجين الايرانيه
نعم نعم
مقر الخارجيه الالمانيه في برلين عيسى